[Música]
Honduras rompe relaciones con Taiwán y
se acerca a China en un comunicado del
gobierno de Xiomara Castro señaló que
taipei hace parte del territorio chino y
reconoce a Beijing como único gobierno
legítimo de esta manera Tegucigalpa
acaba con una relación bilateral que
había iniciado en 1941
la Cumbre iberoamericana llegó a su fin
este sábado tras una reunión de jefes de
estado y de gobierno el encuentro estuvo
enmarcado en discusiones sobre América
Latina y el Caribe como la situación de
Derechos Humanos en Nicaragua y un
llamado a pacificar ahí
Donald Trump volvió a insistir en su
inocencia en la investigación que se
lleva a cabo por presuntamente usar
dineros de campaña para pagar por el
silencio de una actriz porno en 2016
durante su primer evento de campaña en
Texas el expresidente aseguró que lo
están investigando por algo que según él
no es un crimen ni un delito menor
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz iniciamos en
Honduras este sábado el gobierno de
Xiomara Castro oficializó la ruptura de
relaciones con Taiwán cerca de 11 días
después de haber anunciado que iba a
buscar establecer lazos con china
Tegucigalpa señaló en un comunicado que
reconoce a Beijing como único gobierno
legítimo y que Taiwán hace parte del
territorio chino por su parte taipei
rechazó la decisión y anunció que su
embajador en la nación centroamericana
va de regreso al país las noticias se
conoce días antes de la visita de la
presidenta de Taiwán a Estados Unidos
Guatemala y Belice
Honduras reconoce la existencia de una
sola china en el mundo y que el gobierno
de la República popular china es el
único gobierno legítimo que representa a
toda china Taiwán forma parte
inalienable del territorio chino y
finalizó en República Dominicana La
Cumbre iberoamericana un encuentro de
dos días que reunió a jefes de estado y
de gobierno de España Portugal América
Latina y el Caribe y en el que llegaron
a varios acuerdos en temas como el
cambio climático pero también en el que
se generaron divisiones en torno a
situaciones que vive la región desde
Santo Domingo nuestra enviada especial
Rosa Pérez más deu con los detalles
culminó la cumbre iberoamericana número
28 con una muestra de la voluntad
compartida de mayor integración regional
con la adopción de la carta
medioambiental iberoamericana la carta
de los Derechos digitales y de la ruta
crítica para la seguridad alimentaria
Pero entre muchas palabras para mayor
integración regional También muchas
discrepancias que se han evidenciado con
la imposibilidad de adoptar una petición
conjunta de una reforma del sistema
financiero internacional una petición
muy peleada por Argentina pero las
discrepancias también se han hecho
evidentes por el impedimento de adoptar
también de forma unánime una condena de
la invasión rusa de Ucrania Pero además
también ha habido discrepancias en
términos bilaterales por ejemplo el
presidente chileno Gabriel boric ha
condenado lo que ha llamado dictadura
familiar en Nicaragua dictadura familiar
de Ortega y Murillo por otro lado el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
también ha lamentado la ausencia de
Pedro Castillo quien recordemos está en
prisión preventiva en Perú por otro lado
otro de Los ejes ha sido también la
esperanza de que la presidencia Pro
tempore española del Consejo de la Unión
Europea sirva para acercar ambos bloques
y de hecho la voluntad europea para
tener una mayor presencia en América
Latina ha estado personalizada por la
presencia aquí en la Cumbre de josep
borrell El Alto comisionado europeo para
los asuntos exteriores y otro de Los
ejes no que ha estado presente en muchos
discursos ha sido la preocupación por la
situación de Haití sin embargo no se ha
encontrado por el momento un consenso
sobre cómo abordar la situación haitiana
en términos regionales y bien ha
terminado esta Cumbre con el traspaso
por parte del presidente de República
Dominicana Luis abinader al ecuatoriano
Guillermo lasso de la presidencia pro
tempore de la comunidad iberoamericana
que se da cita en Quito en noviembre de
2024 El fiscal general de Venezuela
reveló que más de 20 detenidos ha dejado
la investigación anticorrupción que
condujo esta semana a la renuncia del
poderoso ministro de petróleotará que
laissami quien había servido al gobierno
durante dos décadas el proceso que
comenzó en octubre se centra en la
petrolera estatal pedevesa así como en
la entidad gubernamental que supervisa
las operaciones de criptomonedas y en el
poder judicial nuestra corresponsal en
Caracas Daniela Zambrano nos amplió en
el siguiente informe
funcionarios públicos 11 empresarios y
11 órdenes de captura por ejecutar es el
balance que ofreció el fiscal general
daré William saab tras las recientes
detenciones a funcionarios públicos por
presuntos hechos de corrupción la
mayoría de ellos vinculados a la
industria petrolera el fiscal general
denunció una red de funcionarios
públicos que realizaban operaciones
paralelas a pdvsa que asignaban dineros
a la superintendencia de criptoactivos y
que comercializaban petróleo y cargaban
buques petroleros sin mayores controles
administrativos el fiscal dijo que la
mayoría de delitos que se le ha imputado
a estos detenidos son apropiación
indebida del patrimonio público
asociación para delinquir legitimación
de capitales pero que también se les
imputaría el delito de traición a la
patria dijo además el fiscal que han
logrado recuperar buena parte de los
bienes que se le habían robado a la
nación también el fiscal hizo un balance
sobre órdenes de aprehensión contra
funcionarios del gobierno interino que
presidía Juan guaidó según el balance de
fiscal habría 288 órdenes de aprehensión
y 13 personas con pedido de extradición
recordemos que desde el gobierno se ha
anunciado que esto es un operativo en la
lucha contra la corrupción pero desde la
oposición aseguran que se trate de una
pugna interna dentro del chavismo por el
poder el expresidente estadounidense
Donald Trump volvió a desestimar la
investigación en su contra por
presuntamente haber usado dineros de su
Campaña en 2016 para comprar el silencio
de la actriz porno milenials quien dijo
haber sostenido una relación sexual con
el ex mandatario sus declaraciones se
dieron durante un acto de campaña en
Texas donde lo esperaron miles de sus
seguidores Trump se defendió diciendo
que según él no es un crimen ni un
delito menor Esta es la primera vez que
el nuevamente aspirante a la casa blanca
se deja ver en público después de haber
advertido sin pruebas que iba a ser
arrestado la semana pasada
el fiscal del distrito de Nueva York
bajo el auspicio y la dirección del
departamento
de injusticia en Washington DC me estaba
investigando por algo que no es un
crimen ni un delito menor ni una
aventura
pasamos a Canadá el gobierno de Justin
trude firmó un nuevo acuerdo migratorio
con Estados Unidos para intentar frenar
el creciente número de migrantes que
pasan ilegalmente por su frontera una
decisión que choca con la política
migratoria flexible y amplia que
caracteriza al país norteamericano Alba
Santana tiene los detalles
esta semana Canadá tomó una decisión
dificultar el acceso ilegal al país a
para los migrantes a través de un nuevo
acuerdo fronterizo con Estados Unidos
pero es la migración un problema en el
país norteamericano históricamente
Canadá ha acogido ampliamente a
refugiados de Siria Afganistán y otras
naciones como uno de los países más
abiertos del mundo al respecto pero los
cerca de 40.000 migrantes que cruzaron
la frontera en el 2022 han situado el
tema en el centro del debate con la
oposición pidiendo un nuevo pacto con
Estados Unidos todo porque el acuerdo
migratorio de 2004 tiene un vacío legal
según este Canadá solo puede devolver a
los migrantes que pasen por un paso
fronterizo legal pero si cruzan por
pasos no oficiales como el de rothham
Road entre el estado de Nueva York y
Quebec no pueden devolverlos hasta
resolver su solicitudes de asilo hasta
ahora recordemos que dos de cada tres
solicitudes de Refugio que tuvo ya en
los últimos años fueron precisamente a
esta provincia de Quebec y es por ello
que ya la presión política hacia Justin
crudó estaba muy marcada con el recién
firmado acuerdo del Tercer país entre
Washington y Ottawa ambos países podrán
devolver entre sí a los solicitantes de
asilo en un plazo de 14 días un pacto
que según las rutas migratorias desde
América Latina permitirá que Canadá
devuelva muchos migrantes a Estados
Unidos y a cambio el país norteamericano
aceptará 15.000 solicitudes de asilo en
este 2023 una pequeña fracción teniendo
en cuenta que solo en los dos primeros
meses del año ya ha recibido Diez mil
solicitudes
siempre lo viste canada por televisión y
son países mucho bonita y me gustaría
conocerle de esos países vamos a Porque
en mi país hay mucho sufrido una
decisión que endurece la política
migratoria de Canadá y que ya ha sido
criticada por muchas organizaciones de
defensa de los derechos de los migrantes
y refugiados hasta que es informativo
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]